ils étaient une centaine d'agriculteurs
bouchers et charcutiers mercredi devant
l'abattoir de houdan ou la manifestation
prévue dès antispécistes a finalement
était interdite par le préfet tous ces
professionnels de la filière étaient
présents pour protester contre les
récentes attaques de boucherie notamment
yvelinoise perpétrés par ces militants
de la défense animale nous on a été
caillassé donc vous voyez là c'est ça
c'est la vitrine en vrai donc on a subi
plein d'impact de deux pierres et et un
tag antispécistes mme c'est vraiment la
justice parce que ils s'attaquent à des
gens comme nous qui ne faisons pas de
mal aux animaux
c'est pas nous qui on n'est pas là pour
leur faire du mal au contraire la
filière fait qu en sorte que tout aille
au mieux pour pour le ce1 de des animaux
l'assemblée était également composée de
chasseurs mais aussi de quelques élus
venus soutenir le métier de boucher il
est remis en cause dans la qualité de
son travail aidés dans la nature même de
son travail par des gens dont il ne
connaît même pas le visage et qui se
permettent de détruire son outil de
travail antispécistes contre
professionnels de la viande deux mondes
qui ne se comprennent pas pour les
professionnels du secteur catégorique
sur cette question c'est leur droit de
pas vouloir manger de la viande c'est
notre droit de vouloir en manger et
c'est notre droit dedans produire et je
vois pas pourquoi on remettrait pas en
cause
on demande aux pouvoirs publics de faire
en sorte que ces assauts sur la soit
détruite surface disloqué l'abattoir de
houdan est régulièrement la cible des
antispécistes en 2016 et en avril
dernier les militants s'y était
introduit illégalement pour rendre
compte des conditions d'abattage des
porcs